die hochstufung berlins parteien glückt
konstruktive kritik am programmentwurf
der spd
[Musik]
wenn ihr also ich bin wenn die aus ich
finde ich pantomimisch darstellen wird
thermisch der programmentwurf der spd
inhaltlich überzeugt
[Applaus]
commerzbank
neben gewalt aber es ist wichtig dass
wir stärker in die betreuung unserer
kinder investieren und sie sind unsere
zukunft
okay dann sag mir doch erinnert an den
drei meerschweinchen egal
besonders vermögende bürger sollen einen
höheren beitrag zur finanzierung
öffentlicher investitionen leisten
super idee zurückfahren einerseits
bürger
[Applaus]
steht denn da wirklich gar nichts
konkretes drin in dem programm
mein sohn ist der einkommensteuer nicht
zur rente weil die deutschen film beten
wollen noch bloß nicht anecken
totti war an spd sie war
das ist für die spd in nordrhein
westfalen ein historisch schlechtes
ergebnis
ergebnis die niederlage letzte woche
entschied sich holzer jetzt ein desaster
ein debakel
ich glaube wir können noch gewinnen mit
unserer wurde die meile könnt ihr nicht
[Applaus]
es sind ja noch über vier monate zur
bundeswehr
das müssen wir dazu sagen bei den linken
da sind ja tatsächlich auch ein paar
seltsame leute dabei und sie behandeln
[Applaus]
peter wack